l tutti ragazzi e pm bimbi siamo tornati
sul nostro esclusivo ai per nascondendo
la marca invece di metterla pera o
semplicemente deciso di mettere questa
cosa che più pratica ciao ragazzi su
animal action che adesso avvierò però
aspettate un attimo che devo prima
salutare siri perché sennò poverina non
è giornata
ciao siri e siri non disponibile
connettiti internet
volevi evitarmi
non so se ho capito bene hai capito
benissimo siccome non se in vena di
parlare a via mi animal action che siamo
almeno giochiamo fanno qualcosa
siccome non si in vena di parlare
nessuna applicazione chiamata qualcosa
da rho a via anymore action animal tech
non eni molex com che cosa vuol dire
animal action action l'inglese conosci
l'ing lo sai inglese zia non so se ho
capito bene avevano lo sa l'inglese per
questo animal animal man o e li molla a
via animal animal avi anima l'action io
non ho parole ragazzi io non aver mai mi
sto rifiutando ma memoria no no no no no
cosa in ballo non c'è niente da
festeggiare non sai inglese non sai sci
si sono arrivati i nuovi bestia liszt a
cowes la carta di tutti idioti il codice
di 12 cifre si gioca online ragazzi ciao
se non fare cioè un coso con tre occhi
che parla a dire una guida esseri umani
che le altre gamba per la vostra
opinione
creata dalla nostra unione più
ebbene la sua canzone dio mi ama neanche
martin carica state ma cercarmi ci siano
ragazzi cos'è chi sei
goku l'urbino devo ridere per il tuo
taglio di capelli per il colore dei suoi
capelli o per il nome che c'hai una
delle tre scegli di partite vinte 512
ragazzi ci prova proprio sfidarlo non
posso giocare all aquila mammut barbagia
ecco ecco trovarlo ce lo so il mio
barbagianni di fiducia proviamo una
partita a caldo madonna che bello altri
ce l'hanno a casa vai così non so
neanche come si ma va bene nuove sfide
in eva beck al mondo spiega mi sta
sfidando fermi nessuna sfida e alla
trichet mons in attesa
eccola come fai a chiamarti il kaiser
spiega mi va bene accetto disponile tre
carte per la battaglia va bene voglio il
bar dove barbagia fermi
dov'è il mio barba ecco vogliono subito
ma ne frega niente anche se scarsissimo
me ne frega niente barbagianni ma molte
triceratopo vai e barbagianni ragazzi è
il mio punto di forza forza barba tommy
boy deludermi voi cosa fa emozionato per
la prima sfida non vedi che mi sto
sciogliendo adesso gli animali
sfideranno quindi del tuo avversario all
a1 dai animare più forze ho capito non
fai sfidare grazie da qualcosa
manutenzione questo chi ha vinto ho
vinto io ho vinto io è più forte
barbagianni by bar bar di fargli un
mazzo così gli amico mio che adattano
carica bela tarr la tartaruga di mancata
per una rimonta perfetto era era forte
il giusto mahmood la ragazza troppo
parte c'è basta
cioè lui l'unico ad aver perso è stato
il barbagianni come ho fatto a prendere
come barbagianni e il mio punto di forza
al gat all
agata ma come ti vesti no ma serio cioè
cos'è questa cos'è cosa sei aiutatelo
piano piano giuseppe fultz e beck che
pecca in inglese vuol dire animale dove
c'è animale domestico
quindi giuseppe giuseppe più animale
domestico
giuseppe credo di aver capito allora
funziona così tu metti le carte quindi
tipo elementi sia il sito
metti la metti le carte così poi si
scontrano una una kia la forti è più
forte vince il barbagianni quello che fa
più schifo è più forte al riccio che tra
l'altro sta ballando la breakdance
facciamo tipo tutti per gli storici e di
cerato a caso t rex come fa essere più
forte il triceratopo del t rex spiega
come fanti rex essere così piccolo c'è
un po di differenza tra i due a casa a
bra che ci sono i the beach si evolvono
le carte fantastico non sapevo che anche
il mammut e cioè questo piccolo e cioè
questo che ci ha quattro proboscide va
bene mettiamo di così la ragazzina mary
così diciamo che devo battere il
giuseppe perché se non batto giuseppe
detto non sono nessuno ma mi facci
capire un attimo a prof sono nero ma che
non è che son razzista non sono nero
cioè fatemi cambiamento nel mio ha
innanzitutto sono donna ferrino mettiamo
una sei una pia ecco questa è bellissima
la d'oro fatemi trovato gesuino gesuino
spiegate ma voi ragazzi combattiamo
contro sta tizia che ancora non ho
capito perché mi ha chiesto di sfidarla
perché non sa che io sono un campione in
carica di questo gioco vale infatti ho
già vinto in partenza ciao che sarà
quella dei degli animali preistorici
il 90 è andata lo scorpione è andato
ciao ciao zia è stato bello non ho
scelti perfetto no addio miss abate
vista battendo la tigre ragazze 150 me
ne vado e cioè di neve mills mi alzo e
me ne vado
ciao proprio ciao cosa ci stava ma cosa
ci sta fa cosa ci sta a fare io qua se
dispiegamento di melo
domanda interessante lo sto chiedendo
anch'io mamma la difficoltà grazie zia
noli voglie palloni o un tipo che ha dei
capelli normali semplicemente perché gli
ha nascosti quindi va beh posso fare con
i cuccioli con cuccioli dai parliamo a
barbagianni il primo lamenta espero farò
schifo è sicuramente mi ammazzo però
vabbè dai proviamo riccio detto tipici
tifosi che ciò se vinco sta cosa giro
nudo per casa be lo giuro
siamo ragazzi proprio la provo a vedere
se si può vincere per carità barbagianni
prendere chi sei per devo perdere
proprio affetto bravo più scarso norme
triste triste di perdere porino canguro
bravissimi ragazzi ma battesimi di
diverso l'apocalisse proprio ma
devastato solo utili cuccioli veramente
no ma in teoria perché sono non si
capisce perché esistono i cuccioli
servono per farli evolvere
quindi bisogna dargli la magna dagli da
bere ste cose e poi diventano quelli
grossi adesso questo salito di
esperienza però in battaglia normalmente
fanno schifo di norma proprio fare l'ala
più la combinazione più forte che esiste
fermi harting credo è questa qua forse
no
sono qua grazie grazie non ti vedevo che
l'asse di avermelo detto mi interessa
carta speciale vinta più la mano me la
metto no aspetta fatemi provare chiuso
la stessa combinazione di prima ragazzi
più le speciali ragazzi sparatevi questa
che era lei dovrebbe essere la più paura
di tutt'e tre colpi 36 st formazione col
peuterey dovrei tipo dovrebbe esplodere
i server di animal action credo sei
pronto a morire gesuino ci penso io è
l'ultima che faccio mela ed deve essere
la più devastante convincere 6 a 0 anche
se il massimo 5 ci siamo se va bene e
credo la put è impossibile già e forte
di suo in una maniera imposte più di tre
proprio di cosa stiamo parlando di
barbagia barbagianni io sono barbari j
mi piace perché seriamente se facciamo
un altro girone lui si ricarica tutte le
carte io vinco lo stesso sempre 5 a 0
come come ha fatto a uccidermi la tigre
come hai fatto quello che mi stavo già
sardo di come sarei riuscito a vincere
sarà essi rifatta stavo scherzando c'è
anche selena gomez che non ci somiglia
per niente prove con ragazzi concludo
che episodio ho capito che riesco a
comandare su giochi dove mi regala non
le carte solo perché conosco il creatore
del giorno sono ciao mettete dei limiti
ai nomi strani che scegliete quando vi
registrate online scegliete dei nomi che
si siano almeno pronunciabili va bè
ragazzi concluso poi è stato figo dove
l'episodio ragazzi se volete scaricarlo
vi lascio anche link descrizione mi
piace perche e sui no perché non ho
potuto sfidarla poverino però
so che ci teneva tanto lo so vittoria
vittoria vitale e vitalità sconfitta non
per savona hanno vinte otto ragazzi
credo che episodio spero che vi sia
piaciuto da subito il video bisogna
solamente mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook che con i video tanta mestizia
necessities capiscimi diavolo proseguito
mi raccomando a usare il barbagianni da
ragazzi